recently I replayed a great microbes
adventure game called still life that I
originally played when it first came out
now the issue of 14 year old me playing
a game about a serial killer taking out
prostitutes aside I vividly remember the
main reason I decided to play this game
was because I got my hands on it demo
the demo consisted of the first hour or
so of the full game which gave me the
chance to decide that I really liked the
adventure game mechanics the spot-on
dialogue delivery and I got to
experience the horrifying images of
chopped up women that would punctuate my
nightmares for the next several years
there was a time when almost all of my
game demos came from GameSpot's I didn't
have a lot of money as a young PC gamer
and if me my brother could get into
something for free
you better believe we would as a kid
having that access to the wide world of
video games was awesome but as an adult
it could be even better we could make
more educated decisions about our
purchases based on our own firsthand
judgment and knock somebody else's
if you take a look at origin and Steen's
game demo offerings the latter is hugely
populated by demos for indie games like
the Stanley parable and the Tallis
principle and the odd older title like
portal or Just Cause 2 while origins
offerings are sparse save for demos of a
lot of football games seriously so many
football games while it's great that
some devs are still putting demos out
there really few and far between and you
don't see them from large publishers on
the whole the game demo seems to be all
but dead that is unless you count
multiplayer betas all want to fork out
for subscription services like EA access
which promised full game
trials it's unfortunate that the game
demo has died since they can be so
incredibly valuable for both publishers
and gamers for gamers they can get a
better idea of what they're buying into
and publishers can either use it as an
opportunity to show off their game early
to get people engaged create genuine
and exhibit confidence in their product
there seems to be a fear of letting
gamers take a proper look at a game
before they decide to buy it this seems
evident from the absence of demos right
too late to review embargoes which break
on or after the day of the game's
release
it's as if publishers don't have enough
faith in their game to be able to let it
speak for itself without heavy marketing
strategies and carefully tailored
gameplay trailers or perhaps the games
are so ambitious there's a rush to meet
release date deadlines and there's not a
lot of room left for devs to think about
a distributable demo but if you think
about it demos are made for and exist at
game conventions like packs and gamers
will line up for hours just to get 15
minutes of hands-on with a game they're
interested in why can't we enjoy that
experience in the convenience and the
comfort of our own home last year doom
created John Romero said he reckoned
game distribution should return to a
model that emulate the demos of the 90s
speaking about the good old days Romero
said our entire first episode was free
give us no money play the whole thing if
you like it and want to play more than
you finally pay us to me that felt like
the ultimate fare model
I'm not nickel and diming you I didn't
[ __ ] the game in any design way that
was a really fair way to market a game
Romero emphasized that we aren't in the
age of giant boxed game copies anymore
and that's a very good point we don't
need to rely on box quotes and a
collection of cover art images to decide
how to fork out our hard earned money we
have awesome technology and digital
services that would easily enable gamers
to try before we buy and in a perfect
world more publishers and developers
would believe in their products enough
to let people try a game before they
need to pay 20 40 60 or 80 dollars a
month back EA CEO Andrew Wilson said he
saw the future of gaming as being free
to start we could start a game for free
and then pay for it later but we already
had that 20 years ago so it was a good
idea then and it's a good idea now then
I say bring back the game demo let me
know what you think and if
Sheila game demo has ever had a positive
impact on you I'll see you soon